so we're here at the first light and
Wars which is all about inspiring future
generations of young filmmakers to get
out there and make their short films
tell us a little bit about what inspired
you to get involved in TV and film I
think I've fluked it the first day I
spent on a television set was just as an
extra and prior to that I'd seen TV and
gone off just Kenan Deirdre but it turns
out this Kenan Deirdre and there's Steve
and Dan and Phil and and our million
people that make that happen
and yeah kind of been on set for a first
time that kind of inspired me something
sparked and I kind of kept doing it a
little bit more in a little bit more and
the fire was just coats a bit more and
then that kind of that was the spark I
think yeah we progressed a little bit
since then haven't you being an extra in
Lou so now I got the third series of
that coming out anyway we're still not
been found out but yeah that they'll
come they'll come it's like waiting for
the I gosh catalog man to come and get
yeah it's like right you know but no I
have been terribly lucky but also you
know put everything I mean everything
into what I do and yet Ben did some
great projects and they've got 31 Luther
coming out it was fantastic to do what's
it been like working with Idris again
and great you know we're kind of four
years in now into a promise it's great
no it's a great show we have a you know
a great time film in it because it's
quite dark and quite grim probably not
suitable for these lot but you know you
can't live in that world constantly so
we like to let our hair down and you
know enjoy the time but no it's been
fantastic just I would expect more of
the same deeper darker more gruesome
more zombies people getting killed so
how do you guys let your hair down when
you're on set and what would you what
advice would you give to these future
generations coming if a filmmakers young
actors and directors have I let my hair
down on sand
cup of tea lunch that's when we
that really well you do often we'd often
get a corpse quite a bit and get the
giggles and then you get in trouble
because you can't stop laughing
especially be trying to do a really
serious scene yeah I've got it I've got
it I've got it and the directors getting
a little bit angry now it's taken 20
minutes to do a tiny little okay I've
got it I've got it
and action I do that quite a lot of what
you got coming up and what advice you
give to these guys the future coming up
um I've got a series out at the moment
which just started and I basically say
you know keep going as you're doing
because you're here and it's brilliant
and and keep trying new things like when
I was young I was always like drawing or
painting on and then started making
little films with my camera and I you
know all kinds of things and keep kind
of just expanding and hopefully keep
believing in yourselves because you know
you have and got here and so serious
you've got coming up at Luke it's good
in the flesh on BBC three
you